[Music]
oh god no I don't wanna click it I'm not
gonna get when you click it they say no
to you I say we say no to them if you
don't want my baby they're stupid when I
became a dad I made a choice to support
my daughter's dreams Alex thinks we can
afford tuition and we can't fifty
million dollars thousand honey Oh God
we don't have the money she can't go to
college she got a lie that's what
parents do cuz otherwise the kids are
gonna realize it we don't know what
we're doing
welcome I have a way for you guys to
make four years tuition in one month
underground casino map seems to check
out do this map you're 40 years old and
you go to jail for 20 years how old are
you and you get out 90 no hundred honey
if I have some scratch paper I can
figure it out you want to make money
like Vegas you gotta look like Vegas
we've got a nail salon massages you're
never gonna believe what's in this next
room is it a strip club
[Applause]
what's up that kid a kid's 11 he's a
fantastic DJ drop that beat
[Music]
your mother and I will be working late
every night this cannot but feel like
you're lying
you love you so much we're so proud of
you but you need to shut up what did you
just say so hard being a parent
something fishy going on with those
three gonna bet on our friends fighting
we're casino we ever heard a fight night
Martha more pretty good in there
they both take the same MMA class at the
Y oh gee daughter by the way I love this
so much are those women's sunglasses no
they're tell you I feel like a badass
[ __ ] I'm not gonna tell my daughter she
can't go to college so we resorted to a
life of crime
guys you've got a problem we gotta send
a message like DeNiro casino you think
you can cheat us what are you guys gonna
do about it anyway
well I'm so scared I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna do this hey don't you around
what's come on tell your friends if they
mess with us me you're gonna get it's
the same wedding the same celebration no
matter what table you're out you a guy
you got something grown-up you this is
where I'm sitting so if you end up in
the Haight